all righty everybody welcome back to
another parsing Twitter tutorial this is
where we left off we were just we just
parsed an individual tweet to show
that's how you're going to do it we
added this really long wait time
otherwise you know we would parse the
entire page but the next thing I really
want to do is clean this up because this
kind of sucks we don't want to be
looking at all this stuff so the next
thing that we're going to want to do is
use another regular expression to kind
of clean up the content that we're
pulling so with that next thing we want
to do is print read dot sub and let's
just build a quick regular expression
make sure we're doing it right and if so
then we'll we'll probably assign it
variable to it but anyway so what we
want to do now is if we look at the
source code let me bring it up again
save you'll see that all the stuff that
we don't want right is encased in tags
right we don't want that we don't want
that you know what that we know that and
really almost this entire freaking thing
we don't want but once we get down here
majority may I remind you that morsi won
by the election by a margin bigger than
obama etc that's what we really want we
just want this but we've got all this
junk applied to it that's given to us a
lot twitter so the next thing we want to
do is kind of clean this up a little bit
and the way that we're going to do that
is everything within tags we don't want
because initially you wouldn't want to
do this immediately because initially we
want something very specific between
very specific tags but now we're going
to get rid of all the other tags so what
we're going to do is usual regular
expression for this and it's all tags
and then as you might guess my favorite
little combination everything between
the tags right and then we'll close that
off and then you say with this sub it's
like substitute first you give the
regular expression of the thing you want
to substitute followed by what you want
to substitute it with in this case
nothing and then finally the thing you
want to apply this to
that's going to be item so we're going
to print item and our in attack we're
going to keep our sleep we're going to
stop printing out the original actually
for this will Pratt the original item
and then let me just print a little
spacer here between the two of them so
you can see the difference drag this
over again and so you see okay excuse
offensive language Obama Beck's fascist
regime bubble bowl okay obviously if we
look at this however everything this is
the tweet right this is the actual tweet
that you would see with your eyeballs
but but this is what you know comes
naturally when we're just parsing the
individual tweet at a time so we can see
that our now our regular expression has
done its job we get a the actual tweet
itself and it did obviously come with
this link that the person supplied but
that's the link the person supplied so
you might want to have those if not you
can always use regular expressions to
parse out the links as well so next up
let's close out of this and let's go
ahead and we're going to get rid of
print item we're no longer need to print
the item next thing let's let's make a
little bit of a spacer between the each
element we're about to print out all
twenty elements say let's pop over here
okay and we're going to get rid of this
sleeper here just comment it out now
safe run and drag it over okay here are
all of our tweets now this 20 tweets
basically for all of our information um
so anyway uh so far we've actually
within I don't know how long I've been
yapping but about like 10 minutes
probably where the point where we can
that we're visiting the page and pulling
on the entire search results for the
term Obama now with that let me let's
pop back over to Twitter pull it up
alright now what Twitter is going to do
when you're just sitting there is it
it's very
and you're not getting all of the tweets
like right now it says only 120 new
tweets since the last time well that's
not quite right if we refresh let's
refresh now ok we see we have you know
product - a second in the last you know
for the 15 second there's two of them so
you're getting at least two every second
on Obama
we're refresh again as you can see we've
got now if you look at the 15 second
mark we got for a second there and let's
see if we can even find that okay and
then this was the top tweet in the last
refresh let's zoom back up here we've
got Lexy Martell let's refresh again and
let's find Lexi so scroll down find its
ear we Pat there your stitches okay so
as you can see you're getting definitely
way more than you know the 120 that it
was doing so it's in your best interest
to continue refreshing a Twitter if
you're going to be parsing and trying to
get the most out of your Twitter results
one last thing I'm going to say is you
see how it says 17 seconds 18 seconds
all that no that's not true it's not
real time if we take a moment let me
that's actually here your I'm going to
don't want to pull this down here now
we're going to pull my little hyper
canned and here if I hold my mouse over
here we see it's you know 44:19 p.m.
let's refresh Twitter and then scroll
over here it says 15 seconds not true it
was it's actually two hours ago and
sometimes if you wait long enough this
number will correct itself but we could
also go to like oh my god yes make me an
Obama one let's let's visit this person
if we can well even this is telling us
it's 35 seconds ago it's really not the
I really know what else to say to you
guys besides it's not 35 seconds ago
usually but whatever it's telling us it
is but if a lot of times if you stay
here and just kind of wait a second
you'll find that no it is indeed not it
this number
actually change to two hours normally if
you just waited but for whatever reason
it's not changing for me but like let's
go let's just say query Obama sir -
let's try this what do we do wrong weird
well for whatever reason I can't get it
to change like normally like if you sit
on this page these numbers do change but
for whatever reason they're not changing
for me so but trust me there are two
hours old they're not really real time
even though like it's just weird because
I visit this person's profile and it's
even saying it was that many seconds ago
and usually it doesn't it does it just
doesn't work like that so interesting
maybe it's changed since the last time I
was parsing Twitter maybe it is real
time so so there you go now you can even
get real-time data on Twitter and not
use their API but anyway so it's going
to conclude this video next video maybe
I'm talking about a little bit of a
intuitive way to parse Twitter because
take for example Obama you know there
might be a time when Obama gets let's
say for tweets a second there might be
other time so which would mean you'd
really want to refresh the page every
five seconds there might be other times
where Obama gets one tweet a second in
which case you would want to be
refreshing that page way less right and
let's say you're not even parsing Obama
like let's say you're parsing let's say
dollar sign BBY that's what you're
waiting for there might be times where
there is no news on Best Buy that day
and it's very very slow in which case
you don't want to be refreshing it a
bunch right it's a waste of your own
processing in your own bandwidth but on
days where there's big news for Best Buy
you don't have to go in there every day
and like kind of manually monitor and
change these things right and this
stands really for anything like for
example if you're parsing an RSS feed or
if you're parsing Twitter or if you're
you know who knows what else you might
be parsing but there's a very smart way
to go about how many how often you want
to be parsing these sites so with that
I'll leave you on that cliffhanger at
the moment you should be able to be
parsing Twitter by now no problem
getting at least the tweets that you
want as always thanks for watching thank
you for your support your subscriptions
and until next time